[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue à s'être autre
édition des espaces autochtone en direct
je m'appelle anne-marie vent la semaine
dernière c'était la journée
internationale des femmes et là je me
suis dit faisons donc deux pierres d'un
coup et parlons encore une fois d'un
sujet qui concerne les femmes
un sujet âgé un petit film back dans mon
oreille merci voilà donc un sujet qui
concerne les femmes on va s'intéresser
aux métiers qui ne sont pas
traditionnellement occupés par des
femmes
il y en a de plus en plus il y en a dans
divers milieux
vous allez les découvrir avec nos deux
invités d'abord en skype darwin picard
bonjour dorine bonjour alors dans une
dites nous qui vous êtes votre titre il
est vraiment très long conseillère
régionale mais qu'est ce que vous faites
exactement et pour quel organisme
je suis conseillère régionale et la
maison mais aussi les métiers non
traditionnels
donc les premières nations du québec et
labrador projet de trois ans auquel je
travaille dit non traditionnels
je suis heureux ici et vous partager ce
goût projet alors vous avez préparer une
trousse d'ailleurs qui concerne donc ces
femmes et ces métiers non traditionnels
on va en parler dans quelques instants
mais avant je présente notre deuxième
invité tom cruise bonjour tatum bonjour
vous pratiquer un métier non
traditionnel en fait je dis hein vous en
avez pratiqué plusieurs tout au long de
votre carrière c'est ça tu dois faire en
fait ça peut plus de 25 ans que je fais
des métiers non traditionnels
à l'heure actuelle chiche occupe un
poste de chef d'opération pour la
société de transport de montréal
oui donc mon terrain de jeu c'est
montréal et c'est ce que c'est un métier
non traditionnel ce que vous faites
quand je te dis gestionnaire je vous
dirais que maintenant avec les quitter
on doit avoir de plus en plus de femmes
oui mais c'est majoritairement des
hommes donc à l'époque que j'ai commencé
on était emmené heurté oui mais à
l'heure actuelle on embauche énormément
de femmes
c'est une bonne nouvelle et puis mathis
arvela cette semaine avec nous un
remplacement des discounts bonjour
matisse ou alors vous aussi vous vous
êtes intéressé à une profession qui a
été très très longtemps évidemment tenus
par des hommes
on se bat on veut parler de l'industrie
minière en fait des mineurs femmes
particulièrement à barbonne qui est une
mine de nickel qui se trouvait dans le
land québec au nunavik donc encore une
fois il ya plein de métiers qui sont de
plus en plus où les femmes se targue une
place oui c'est tout un métier en plus à
des travail de fond des mines là et dont
vous allez nous parler de de l'intérêt
peut-être grandissant je sais pas on va
voir des femmes pour ces métiers là on
va découvrir ça un petit peu plus tard
d'abord darwin je me tourne vers vous on
va parler de cette trousse trousse
d'outils différents outils pour les
femmes autochtones qui ont envie de
pratiquer des métiers non traditionnels
pour les employeurs et pour tous ceux
qui donnent de la formation dans ce
domaine
donc l'idée de la trousse allers venues
comment en fait c'est un projet comme je
sais pas autour de trois ans ça a été
financée par un condition féminine
donc lorsqu'on parle de médecine
traditionnelle
vocabulaire qui est très nouveau travail
qui est méconnu donc anglais commettre
reflète d'abord le nombre limite de
femmes y avait un métier non
traditionnel à travers le québec
donc on a fait des recherches des études
et on a consulté aussi des femmes des
questions de formation et des employeurs
dans cette poule
parmi les femmes inspirantes dans les
latinos france met donc en sachant en
faisant petit
ces études laser à chercher à une
consultation là et de la red bull est
venue de labourer pour pouvoir augmenter
le nombre de femmes dans les métiers
notamment parce qu'on continue rendu
compte à travers les équipements qui ont
été réalisés que très très peu de femmes
dans les multi notre éternelle on compte
0 point 4 % qui même point 1% en fait de
faim alors que j'écrivais 3 repart de
zéro attendu dans certains métiers
donc au niveau des femmes autochtones
travail à faire notre but ou dire dès le
départ c'était d'intel la parité mais où
ce sera très la parité dans les coeurs
le pourcentage est très pâle acquis 10
0%
donc la trousse d'outils en fait c'est
vraiment un outil vraiment magnifique
les très bien bien battre donc qui cible
d'abord les femmes autochtones parce
qu'on s'est rendu compte à travers les
consultations en avait mentionné qu'il y
avait très peu de modèles et on voulait
aussi voir reconnaître des multi métiers
locaux
aussi les femmes sont vraiment
passionnés par la houle alors leur
métier et on le voit d'ailleurs à
trégunc à vers les images les les
émotions des épanouis dans leur
profession professionnelle est aussi bon
on vise également les questions de
formation
donc on exclut à travers ses trousses
des pratiques qui peuvent se mettre en
place dans la restitution pour attirer
justin des femmes a étudié des mythiques
on connaît pas nécessairement et on
donne également des conseils
commentaires promotion comme en été
j'en autochtone avant
dans leur programme est ce que c'est ça
dans wind vous parliez tout à l'heure
donc des femmes en général mais les
femmes autochtones sont particulièrement
ciblés par le manque d'emplois dans des
métiers qui sont non traditionnels plus
que chez les femmes en général oui
exactement
c'est quand qu'on le compare avec les
québécoises par exemple quand on parle
de métiers non traditionnels et c'est
selon au québec un homme de profession
et à travers cette profession aux a donc
peu de femmes qui ont des métiers non
traditionnels pour nous on veut
encourager les femmes à a été à un habit
gay ou aller vers des métiers qui sont
lourds malheureusement dans l'école
auquel on s'attend pas qu'une femme
puisse faire en fait ça c'est votre cas
tu es tome vous avez commencé en fait
toute votre vie vous avez fait des
métiers non traditionnels pour les
femmes
oui tout à fait en fait état plus jeune
j'avais pas de facilités au niveau
scolaire donc pour moi j'ai décidé à ma
mère m'avait demandé de l' l'école puis
bon ben je t'aime passionné de voitures
donc j'ai décidé de commencer en
mécanique automobile pour me rendre
compte assez vite que finalement jamais
pas malgré ces les mains et puis ya volé
un an soudure
puis c'est quelque chose qui me
passionnait donc j'ai transféré de
développer parce que c'est un diplôme
d'études professionnelles
oui donc j'ai fait mon monde il paie en
soudure en soudage-montage puis après
belge spécialisée pour la haute pression
et puis je t'avais travailler en fait
pendant dix ans pratiquement dix ans
comme cela rassembleur pour différentes
grosses compagnies donc c'est ce que
j'ai fait c'est quoi ton des usines qui
construisent autour d'un coin de ma tête
j'ai travaillé moi je faisais le système
de freinage pour alstom canada qui était
pour les trains cette compagnie se
contractant qui s'appelait sainte je
travaille et j'ai fait j'ai fait des
très large et futurs de projets les gros
cheminée pour les grosses compagnies en
fait là c'est comme une grosse piscine
avec une super anglaise puis bon je
travaille i wanna mais ce faire un
proche à l'époque vous étiez dans un
métier non traditionnel n'y avait pas
beaucoup de femmes et en plus vous êtes
une femme autochtone a fait ça faisait
beaucoup de minorités pour vous là
comment vous avez été reçu par les
hommes qui travaillaient là j'imagine
que vous devienne une des rares femmes
ouais en fait je vous dirais qu'elle le
chemin n'a pas été toujours facile parce
que je sois main - ce qui est à lui et
c'est que on a tout un test à passer
pour le sceau rouge donc on doit avoir
en fait c'est un test de soudure puis
moi je sortais de l'école donc c'est à
ce moment là c'est avec ton point de vue
qu'on va savoir si c'est toi qui va
faire des cas qui va avoir des
inspections
donc faut que tu as studio faut que ça
soit on pense à toi donc sur les 15 sud
a rejeté à seul qui avait réussi à
passer mais je l'étais la dernière aussi
à rentrer fait que ça n'a pas été facile
de stock hôtel puis nous les femmes ont
une facilité une dextérité qui est
facile pour le soudage aux mig au tig
aussi parce que c'est très délicat
donc je travaillais dans ce métier-là
puis je me suis vraiment spécialisés
spécialisés dans ce domaine
mais si on les 15 qui était qui est
entré vous étiez la seule femme oui en
fait j'étais la seule femme
donc ça n'a pas été facile sa peau tout
le temps je te dirai moi j'avais
beaucoup de caractère attends aide
salah el plus tranquillement je pense
qu'on fait tomber les barrières
oui en effet d'ailleurs dorina ce qui a
encore beaucoup de barrières à faire
tomber aujourd'hui
ah oui en effet nous dans le processus
on est vraiment dans des bus
oui on a créé des outils a maintenant un
fou les accusés savoir les utiliser
et c'est différent pour les communautés
on les estime formation mais aussi pour
les employeurs donc
il ya des parias personnel il ya des
barrières système
c'est vraiment un travail collectif
comme doit s'investir le port vraiment à
faire un changement et augmenter le
nombre de femmes dans les médecines
traditionnelles donc les modèles comme
tatum je pense commence à nous en prend
plusieurs pour encourager de doute femme
plongée traditionnels est-ce que du côté
des employeurs il ya aussi beaucoup de
barrières à faire tomber ou est ce
qu'ils sont de plus en plus conscients
de la réalité on est en 2019 et que la
place des femmes elle est partout dans
la société et donc ils ont mis à rire en
fait le constat est actuellement vous
savez bon il ya une premire et la main
d'oeuvre on en parle
vers les années évidemment il ya un
passé de main d'oeuvre disponible autant
h et les impacts mais aussi chez les
femmes autochtones donc de plus en plus
les communautés soupe pour offrir là des
gens disponibles à paris mais aussi des
employeurs qui souffre donc c'est
vraiment très positive
maintenant c'est de travailler en
partenariat ensemble parce que la
réalité est différente en partie demain
ou québécoises où par exemple qu'est ce
que vous voulez disque en jeu dans ce
sens qu'il est bon culturellement
différentes par exemple de la langue où
il ya une façon par exemple est réservée
[Musique]
avec estime de soi par exemple mais
c'est déjà ce travail est défoncée
question personnalités défendant tonnes
sont sentis mais par qui
[Rires]
c'est donc un beaucoup de travail à
faire a installé là c'est juste de se
concerter puis trouver des façons de
comment intégrer les femmes étaient
cantonnés à leur métier leur emploi oui
je voyais d'ailleurs dans la trousse
vous voulez démonter la toutes sortes de
mythes et montrer la réalité telle
qu'elle est aujourd'hui parce que c'est
vrai que des mythes y en a il y en a
plein il y en a vraiment de toutes
sortes et autant autant complètement
illogique bon des mythes qui sont
vraiment ancré dans la société mais vous
avez voulu démonter exactement oui on
est vraiment fier de ce travail qui a
conquis mais en fait les mythes on envie
je pense tous les jours le revenant des
femmes autochtones qui ont participé à
la consultation leur vécu reflète
beaucoup
est ce que vous êtes toujours là dorine
on vous a perdu alors pour l'instant en
images et on va essayer de récupérer de
rides mais de votre côté taye tome on va
continuer parce que vous avez tout un
cheminement vous êtes passés dans de
mécanicien auto way as ou deux mais ça
s'est pas arrêté là
non en fait dans les airs à cassen enfin
c'est hyper intéressant c'est le métier
de soudeur manège avait besoin de plus
toujours derrière un casse et c'est un
travail que oui on parle de quelque
chose
point au jusqu'au point b mais on montre
le projet mais à la toute fin j'avais
besoin de challenge puis j'avais un
modèle qui était ma mère que j'avais vu
ma mère poursuivre ses études jusqu'au à
la maîtrise mais je me disais mais
pourquoi que pourquoi moi j'aimerais ça
peut-être je me voyais bien aussi parce
que cela métier qui est très physique
donc rentrer chez moi avec les mains
noires puis les brûlures c'est arrivé
souvent puis je me voyais pas 40 50 ans
fassent leur métier l'onu
fait que ce soit finalement je décide de
retourner à l'école puis qui était un
autre gros défi parce que bon je pensais
que j'avais que je t'ai pas vraiment bon
à l'école
donc je te les faire un dec en
intervention délinquance
j'ai poursuivi quelques cours à
l'université puis j'ai travaillé comme
comme agent de programmes pour service
correctionnel canada ou professionnels
au provincial qu'au fédéral mais c'était
contractuel donc ça a été le monde mon
background le belge tranquillement j'ai
fait des travaux la commission scolaire
je travaille pour femmes autochtones du
québec
j'ai fait plusieurs emplois puis moi ce
que je voulais c'est avoir un poste
permanent parce que je voulais fonder ma
famille pour lui c'est important pour
moi de avoir une stabilité financière
donc et puis finalement il ya quelqu'un
qui m'a dit mais pourquoi tu postules
pas comme comme chauffeur d'autobus pour
la stm le concours est très difficile
donc c'est ce que j'ai fait mais moi ça
a été très rapide vraiment rapide puis
au moment où ce qu'on me dit mon team
adam kane vous devez passer l'examen de
conduite donc je me servirai de bord je
demande aux femmes autochtones du québec
pouvez vous payer mon cours de conduite
pour véhicules au donc c'est ce que j'ai
fait et puis j'ai commencé à travailler
comme chauffeur d'autobus monde en cinq
ans que j'ai fait ça pendant 5 1 mais je
me suis rendu compte que sa cliente s
est pas mon fort
l'expérience rien donc j'avais besoin de
challenge puis a demandé mais je me suis
dit
j'étais sur le point de quitter l'est m
quand quelqu'un me dit applique donc
comme gestionnaire la société de
transport de montréal puis c'est ce que
j'ai fait sans aucune pensée sans savoir
ce qui s'était quoi le travail
et puis rendu à deuxième entrevue j'ai
appelé mon patron pour vour avoir plus
d'informations puis c'est là que je lui
rendis compte que en fait la ville de
lorient c'est d'arriver intervenir dans
des situations de crise qui se passe
dans nos autobus les accidents les des
taux les feux tout ce qui se passe quand
une personne qui a un malaise
jésus binger doit ses plus beaux métiers
donc j'étais en plus mais à tous les
soirs je rentre chez moi donc j'ai une
qualité de vie et puis ça a été ça donc
ça fait 12 ans que je thales et chez les
gestionnaires il ya beaucoup de femmes
en fait je vous dirais que sur 150
gestionnaire je vous dis c'est
approximativement peut-être quarantaine
de la femme ou c'est pas beaucoup et de
femmes autochtones encore moins à celle
à sal je n'en doute pas il fallait la
seule alors pour vous daury parce que
vous êtes de retour avec nous merci de
revenir
est-ce que l'exemple de tatum c'est un
exemple vraiment intéressant lorsque
vous allez voir des employeurs ou à
d'autres femmes
ben en fait oui il ya d'autres
employeurs quand même pas de deux
autochtones et ils y ont pas non plus de
femmes autochtones mais par contre ils
ont plus les employeurs veulent intégrer
des autochtones ou des femmes
autochtones
une scène de la désorganisation de leur
entreprise et c'est ce qui est donc une
bonne nouvelle en fait pour vous
mais non de notre côté aussi il faut
croire collaborent pouvoir
ces femmes se retrouvent et au soir en
milieu oui donc non les i je vous ai
coupé non ça va j'ai encore excellent
alors on va parler d'une région je sais
pas si vous le couvrez le nord le nord
du québec est ce que vous allez jusqu au
nunavik à travers ce programme et la
trousse
nous on a fait quand qu'on parle des
autochtones ça inclut communauté
autochtone mais aussi les premières
nations
oui en fait lisez oui en effet les
inuits aussi aussi d'accord me semble
qu'ils avaient justement dans votre
trousse et j'ai cru je pense que j'ai vu
j'ai vu la fiche de jeunes femmes
d'iqaluit tout je pense qu est agent de
sécurité exactement et s'appelle
emmanuel et kalou et john abbott
oui l agente de sécurité sécurité donc
vraiment fière d'elle les inuits donc on
a essayé de voir comment cela de toutes
les femmes
[Musique]
exactement
parce que les femmes inuit dans ce cas
là avec vous mathis on parle du nunavik
la mine du nord du québec les femmes
inuit évidemment veulent entrer sur le
marché du travail aussi des métiers non
traditionnels ne sont pas nombreuses et
surtout pas lorsque c'est pour
travailler dans des mines un exemple
exactement puis en fait je vous dirais
que l'industrie minière c'est encore
souvent perçu comme une industrie
majoritairement masculine oui mais il ya
plusieurs facteurs quand même avec le
temps dont je pense à l'automatisation
des technologies qui ont fait quand même
que les femmes se sont le plus en plus
taillé une place puis aussi plusieurs
entreprises vous l'avez dit stoner
madame car qui ont pour anticiper une
éventuelle pénurie de main d'oeuvre ont
décidé de se mettre en marche et
d'embaucher plus de faim mais bon plus
de top-ten et donc le jeu on va parler
de la mine wendy et ça
on avait qui situe entre les communautés
salle où étaient en guerre sous trois
axes d'une centaine de kilos mais on est
vraiment au nord aussi extrême nord du
québec donc on est dans la péninsule
d'ungava une centaine de kilomètres au
sud de la baie déception pour ceux qui
seraient passés contraire qui se
connaissent le secteur donc cette
mineure est en service est en production
depuis 97 elle est détenue par glencore
depuis 2013 à peu près et parmi les
mille 150 employés on retrouve on trouve
à peu près une femme sur cinq parmi les
employés qui sont en fait parmi 20 % des
employés sont des femmes dans le site
min whee sur le cidre au guidon cas peut
être se retrouver parce qu'on va
travailler la cafétéria comme ça alors
j'allais emmené en fait souvent ce qui
se passe c'est que les
les personnes qui soient femmes ou
hommes autochtones dans certaines vont
penser que sur 1,7 million on ne peut
qu'être mineurs mais finalement vous
aurez une bonne reprise emplois qu'ils
ont qui peuvent être possible de des
ressources humaines ou au département de
l'environnement à la restauration la
santé épisode donc le métier de soudeur
par exemple de machinerie
machinerie lourde louer et donc en fait
quand je me suis intéressé à la
proportion de femmes autochtones et
métiers non traditionnels et les sites
non traditionnels grâce à la mine puis
en fait qui est donc quatre mineurs de
la mine raglan parmi lesquels deux
femmes inuites seulement donc c'est
assez impressionnant parmi les plus de
1000 employés qui travaillent et j'ai
communiqué avec l'une d'entre elle qui
est à l'heure où on se parle doit être
sous terre oui vu que jamais de la clé
d'origine a dit notre joie depuis qu'il
travaille depuis 2012 et elle me dit
elle a peu connu d'embûches
l amo dis moi dans mon travail j'ai
toujours senti que j'ai été valorisé
puis à la mine puis j'ai pas senti de
différence
elle a pas senti qu'elle avait et
étiquetés ou qu'elles sont est
stigmatisée bon parce qu'elle était une
femme femme noire
oui et puis donc mais la proportion de
familles nouettes est extrêmement
extrêmement rare alors que pourtant
c'est sur leur territoire oui exact mais
en fait ce qui se passe ici c'est que la
minière va beaucoup à les embaucher les
inuit de manière générale on n'est pas
encore au stade d'embaucher des famines
reid précisément c'est sûr qu'on est sur
un territoire conventionnés donc sous la
convention de la baie james et du nord
québécois
donc c'est sûr que les entreprises ont
l'obligation l'obligation pardon de
partager les bénéfices avec les
communautés autochtones et si on est
dans mon avis oui
donc c'est beaucoup plus la bouche de
nous et je n'avais que dix noix du
nunavut qui sont juste au nord
donc voila et les les inuit de manière
générale représente aussi 20% donc tous
sexes confondus
quand on regarde dans l'industrie
minière au québec et au canada on est
beaucoup dans les mêmes chiffres
pour les femmes c'est à peu près 20% ce
qui fait que on se demande un peu
pourquoi si aussi peu de familles
plusieurs hypothèses qui sont cités le
manque de modèles donc dans les postes
de haute direction et donc de montreur
difficulté de se voir de voir évoluer et
cheminer dans notre prison en atteignant
un poste de haute direction
il ya aussi la minière si beaucoup le
fait qu' il pense que les gens
méconnaissent la panoplie d'emploi qui
peut y avoir sur le site souvent les
gens pensent que pour travailler sur une
mini forcément était mineure deux skis
est pas tout à fait le cas et on s'en
doute finalement aussi l'argument de la
conciliation travail famille
aucune femme enceinte qui est admis sur
le site alors à gwen pour des raisons de
sécurité mais surtout d'isolement ya pas
deux il ya pas de médecin et sur place
l'équipement médical à temps plein il ya
un boeing qui te quitte la mine par jour
donc bon pour cette raison il n'y a pas
de faire mon scènes qui peuvent être
présents donc ça va faire beaucoup de
portes à des à plusieurs femmes et aussi
tout le système fly in fly out je sais
pas ce type familière avec en sus mais
non c'est ça notre immense alternance de
deux semaines sur place deux semaines de
retour dans le sud ou dans la communauté
d'origine
donc il peut être parfois assez
contraignant oui donc c'est ça mais
comme je le disais tout à l'heure c'est
ça c'est trouver des familles nous est
minée depuis ça reste encore à être
encore difficile
la minière et beaucoup sur l'embauché de
nous est
et en fait à terme il souhaiterait que
100% de leurs employés soit et nous
mettons que du long terme
tom est ce que en tant que ce 2 vous
seriez montée comme ça dans le nord ah
ben oui moi certaines manches j'ai fait
plusieurs travail qui m'a apporté 1 à
différents endroits pour les compagnies
mais à cette époque là j'ai je
connaissais pas vraiment les mines mais
je dois t'avouer que dernièrement j'ai
regardé beaucoup pour ta tasse théo la
même règle a effectivement faire un
travail de gestionnaire par contre ce
qui m'intéresse le moins bien c'est j'ai
trois enfants
on va suivre ça c'est moins facile ça
c'est moins facile
oui bon c'est ça alors mathis pour
recruter les inuit j'imagine qu'on a mis
un peu comme cette trousse d'outils
programme en place pour les aider
savoir ce qu'il a à faire est absolument
le faire donc pour mettre les bouchées
d'audience que ce qu' ils ont fait à la
mine wayne c'est de mettre en place en
2008 le programme tamatoa ni second
départ en octobre puis dans le fond ce
programme de développement d'embauché de
personnel
i know it hommes et femmes oui donc ce
qu'ils ont mis en place c'est l'ami
nicole leur à glen qu'ils appellent
c'est un espèce de programmes de
formation terrain de 2 ans ou
la personne n'a pas besoin c'est la vie
dans une communauté du nord d'aller
faire sa formation sont des bêtes dans
ce cas ce qu'on sait qu'il protégeait
pas d'université on navigue donc ce
programme terrain fait en sorte qu'après
deux ans la personne est formé puis peut
aller dans une autre mine travail et
donc ce programme la gueule jumelage
aussi avec des sous forme de mentorat
avec un employé d'expérimenter sur place
et aussi le fait qu'elle et les les
les employés peuvent faire visiter à
leurs familles la mine sa s'est
autorisée seulement aux autochtones aux
inuit peau aux employés non autochtone
qui est l'autorisation si donc il ya
plusieurs types de possibilités qui sont
qui de d'efforts qui sont mis à travers
ce programme pour aller recruter le plus
18 mai mais pour aller chercher des
femmes ce n'est pas encore un et famille
nous aide c'est pas encore c'est pas
encore l'objectif premier
oui comment vous faites dorine justement
pour intéresser les femmes à ces métiers
non traditionnels
sauf que comme je disais un sa main
la trousse d'outils ya tout juste deux
autres crèches
elle est sortie quoi il ya deux semaines
à peu près c'est ça elle est disponible
depuis deux semaines exactement
on avait un lancement de la douce le 26
février
donc c'est super pour nous on a encore à
faire avant auprès défendre ou à
destination des employeurs l'échelle
régionale
donc c'est sa clientèle type communautés
et des leçons est difficile de riz non
vous entends difficilement va essayer de
régler le son pendant ce temps là on va
parler avec tes temps parce que vous
avez travaillé en collaboration avec
dorine pour cette trousse ya qu est ce
que vous êtes qu'est ce qu'on vous a
demandé pour pour la trousse en fait
d'orner
visiter à mon lieu de travail donc voir
un peu mon métier c'est qu'est ce que je
fais oui à tous les jours puis prendre
des photos puis puce est simple deux
semaines lors de la sortie de la trousse
mer ont été invités à partager un peu
mon histoire donc mon cheminement pour
les jeunes parce que les jeunes ont
besoin d'avoir un modèle que de voir que
c'est possible
donc c'est important parce que moi si on
m'avait dit assez zinc et qu'à mon âge
c'est ce que je fais j'avais des
matériaux par foyer à ma charge
j aurais pas cru donc puis malgré tout
tout le parcours
c'est tout des expériences donc puis
c'est important de d'avancé puis d'avoir
des jarrets me savoir si quand j'étais
plus jeune ça n'existait pas
j'avais juste un organisme qui existe et
c'est le front en fait on était peu de
femmes qui étaient qui était un
organisme orient pour les femmes en
médecine traditionnelle mais aujourd'hui
je me dis pour les jeunes qui sont en
communauté mais y ont besoin de ça
justement puis puis de venir voir un peu
comment ça se passe parce
qu'effectivement il n'ya pas de sot
métier
en effet tout à fait en effet est-ce que
vous allez justement dans les
communautés voir les jeunes ou est-ce
que vous allez y aller ce que c'est
prévu
en fait on m'a invité plusieurs fois
dans les communautés donc les
communautés m'approche puis je veux je
vais un peu partagé mon histoire dit que
j'étais un décrochage scolaire puis
mange explique un peu quand même au
parcours parce que bon avec le temps je
me suis rendu compte que je fais au delà
de cela la dyslexie mais à l'époque moi
je connaissais possédant mongrain donc
aujourd'hui on a des outils nécessaires
donc mais j'avais une facilité d'avoir
un plan 3d donc un plat pour rouler sous
en soudure j'étais capable de le voir
tandis que les femmes c'est quelque
chose qui est plus difficile
tous avouent travailler différemment
marianne dailloux ce que j'explique aux
jeunes
de continuer puis de la persévérance et
de laisser tomber les préjugés ce qu'on
aime
effectivement elle va vendre aux
victimes qu'est ce que vous sentez que
des jeunes justement qui vous avait
parlé qui en qui il voit un peu comme un
modèle ou qui se sont vus à travers vos
les métier que vous avez exercé en fait
c'est drôle parce que manouche est
invité à oicha pour aller faire une
conférence dans un école secondaire puis
après manger une demande facebook puis
la jeune à me dire que c'est venu me
chercher puis bon ben c'est l'important
c'est juste ça c'est juste de donner
l'espoir puis le plus moi c'est ce que
je veux pas ce que c'est les leaders de
demain faction important justement je
veux kahn a de plus en plus de jeunes
femmes autochtones les jeunes qu'ils
puissent vendre le marché du travail est
d'aller voir puis tyler wright l'idée la
cedh allumer l'étincelle d'affaires
devrait absolument dans rénovert on va
vérifier avec vous si le son est revenu
comme il faut des exemples comme tom y
en a plusieurs dans la trousse
d'ailleurs et dans différents corps de
métiers parler nous donner nous d'autres
exemples de femmes que vous avez
approché qui peuvent raconter leur vie
leur expérience m ben en fait d'autres
exemples qui est pas nécessairement qui
recense 25 ans à bapaume et un emmerdeur
donc toujours un pareil dans un métier
traditionnel et qui voulaient découvrir
la rue et jean veil orientation scolaire
professionnelle des femmes qui avaient
par exemple n'est pas qu'un ministre à
sion ou en sciences politiques et elles
ont décidé de recruter et maintenant il
y en a eu assez de travail pour au
québec
donc cette fable ma peau elle est
vraiment à part parce qu'elle fait et
aussi qu'on parle de chantage
j'apprends temps limité pour prat
une façon de produits et métiers en
sorte d'avant match voilà on vous perd
beaucoup de hrinova est obligé de vous
laisser aller merci beaucoup de nous
avoir parlé de la trousse amour si
rapidement une dernière question la
trousse à outils c'est disponible pour
qu'ils en quelques mots havel est
disponible pour tout les coups et femmes
les formats sont les employeurs et même
comme arme était en plein dans aussi sur
le marché de l'emploi elle est
disponible à la merci beaucoup dorine je
sais que vous allez est en formation un
peu partout à travers la province au
cours des prochains jours j'imagine que
vous allez parler de cette fameuse
trousse à outils alors bonne route et
puis à très bientôt merci merci beaucoup
voilà qu'est ce que vous espérez teyton
pour les prochaines années pour vous
personnellement ou est-ce que vous voyez
par exemple dans dix ans et puis qu'est
ce que vous espérez pour les jeunes
femmes autochtones qui ont envie de
suivre votre voix oh mon dieu tout en
question en fait j'espère est toujours à
l'emploi de la stm parce que j'adore ce
que je fais donc probablement je
changeais de domaine en fait d'un haut
niveau peut-être un poste un peu plus
haut on ne vous le concède la compagnie
et puis pour les jeunes mais écoute pour
moi c'est hyper important j'ai trois
jeunes enfants dont deux filles et nous
était oui un garçon qui est qui et
autochtone au moins c'est hyper
important que ça soit que ce soit
accessible depuis j'espère que peu
importe maintenant les communautés que
ces jeunes là ils vont ils vont y aller
de l'avant parce que c'est important
puis tout ce qui crée qui m'ont créé
dans n'importe quel domaine c'est sa
salle apporte la confiance en soi je
suis en même temps mais c'est valorisant
d'être autonome de pouvoir pouvoir se
payer des choses plus d'être pour notre
famille pour nos enfants
donc j'espère que justement c'est cette
trousse à outils leur permettant aux
jeunes aux moins jeunes de
des allez petit français oui alors en
terminant je vais donner le nom de trous
ça s'appelle les femmes autochtones dans
les métiers non traditionnels
le sous titre est vraiment intéressant
de la passion les carrières et les
compétences n'ont pas de sexe
c'est tellement vrai et puis dans cette
trousse il ya quatre chapitres en fait
un qui est destiné aux femmes
autochtones un autre aux femmes en
général un autre aux institutions de
formation un autre employeur et le
dernier chapitre donc des ressources et
des services en emploi et formation
alors je pense que pour toute femme
autochtone qui a envie de se lancer là
dedans c'est une trousse qu'elle doit
absolument se procurer merci tu es comme
des balises et nous voir ici en studio
merci infiniment merci matisse la
semaine prochaine vous ne serez pas vous
serez peut-être avec moi on va partir à
wendake et la semaine prochaine on s'en
va dans les studios de la socam donc la
société de radiodiffusion qui s'occupe
des missions en langues
inoue en langue attikameks un peu
partout à travers la province
alors je vous invite à nous y retrouver
ce sera donc vendredi prochain merci au
revoir
[Musique]